hello everyone I'm Jason Johansen the
homicide Lieutenant with the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department and I'm
here today to ask for the community's
assistance in solving the murder of
Graciela Gomez approximately one year
ago on Halloween weekend October 31st of
2021 Graciela Gomez was attending a
Halloween party in the 200 block of
Beasley drive while she's attending that
Halloween party it quickly began to get
out of hand as it was advertised on
social media as it began to get out of
hand several subjects were turned away
from the front entrance to the party and
returned their vehicle as that vehicle
drove away from the residents Southbound
on Beasley drive it fired numerous
gunshots into the front of the residence
unfortunately as a result of that
shooting
three people were struck Graciela Gomez
and two other females those two other
females thankfully suffered Now by
threatening injuries Graciela
unfortunately was transported to the
hospital and was later pronounced
deceased
today we are releasing video that we've
obtained as a result of our
investigation from the houses nearby
where the shooting occurred in this
video it shows the vehicle driving by
and shooting into the residence and
fleeing Southbound on Beasley Drive our
hopes is that by releasing this
information it will Garner somebody's
memory and someone will provide us a tip
that will lead to the identification of
those responsible for the shooting of
Graciela Gomez I urge anyone with any
information related to this
investigation to please contact Crime
Stoppers of Nevada or reach out to the
lvmpd homicide section your information
will remain anonymous and there is
reward money available thank you
foreign